there's that weird thing that you know
you do bear a kind of quite a striking
resemblance to him yeah yeah this guy I
was able to do a lot of research and the
director of our movie Joe Burrell
injured brought out so much information
because he was also simultaneously a
documentary so I had loads of I I could
spend three like three weeks watching
material on Ted Bundy yeah yeah but
after a while I learned that some of I
could pick up the basic things like
mannerisms certain ticks and things like
that but I didn't want to make you tread
a fine line between doing an
impersonation and I had a good one that
just becomes an impersonation yeah and
making a three-dimensional character
that your audience can associate with so
yes it is that challenge isn't it of
playing playing a real person doing the
like a transformation rather than an
impersonation and we must mention
monster where we did such an
extraordinary job of that but it was
[Applause]
on a Tuesday morning you don't you don't
ever want to feel like you're just doing
that one-dimensional thing and yeah I
definitely like I didn't want to do
prosthetics I gained a lot of weight for
it but I did I did no prosthetics I did
fake cheese and eye lenses fake teeth
are crazy eyed fake teeth and Bundy you
never did any prosthetics no prosthetics
that's just my fat face and I mean had
this facial expression with her mouth
her attention was always in her mouth
and in her eyes and like you I just
watched a lot of documentaries and try
to you know I agree with him it's a fine
line where you don't want to just look
like you're doing a skit yeah you you
want to understand the person from the
inside out and sometimes that informs
you in how they tell their story
behaviorally but you don't want to just
have it be that you want it to be a
little bit
[Music]